Masaya défie mon homme d'accord nouveau copain tu
sais torchon si fausse excavation t
Incheon Songdo Jackie je ne reviendrai jamais
ouais je pensais que tu sais parce que je
pense que la chanson est c'est juste incroyablement
jolie c'est très tu sais ça en dit
tellement tu sais  il faut une
personne très jeune pour dire les choses que
cette chanson dit et et ils ont dit que c'est
très expliquer vous savez ce n'est pas
difficile vous n'avez pas besoin d'être un érudit
pour le comprendre et bien sûr je suis un
sentimental  au fond j'aime les
chansons d'amour je pourrais tu sais et je n'ai pas
je n'ai jamais rencontré mr.  Braille
mais j'aime sa musique et nous nous
sentons évidemment l'un l'autre parce que c'est une
si belle chanson si tu t'en vas car je sais que tu le feras tu
dois le dire au monde
Oh - arrête de tourner jusqu'à ce que tu revienne
si jamais tu fais ça
t'aimer peux je te le dis maintenant
tu pars
Je ne m'arrêterai jamais si tu pars tu
pars si tu pars
mais si tu restes
je ferai de toi un chevalier comme aucun chevalier ne l'
a été
assieds-toi sur ta poitrine
je parlerai à
j'aime tellement la chanson
oh va-t'en va-t'en
oh
toi
j'aurais été l'ombre de ton chien si j'avais
pu arrêter
je me rends compte si tu pars si tu pars
si tu pars
c'est juste